première annonce d'importance le circuit
il reste inchangé avec une boucle de 2
km 7 qui emprunte les voix les plus
larges du centre-ville les bois de
Jacques seront interdites de circulation
en dehors de ce circuit et sol 35
d'entre elles du Mans contrôlés seront
autorisés la sécurité aussi sera
renforcée nous allons intensifier les
points de palpation pour éviter qu'il y
ait des objets illicites qui rentrent
sur le circuit et cette année
particulièrement les groupes de carnaval
ont accepté de jouer le jeu et de se
faire fouiller pour éviter qu'il y ait
des personnes qui en profitent qui
profitent de leur passage pour ancrer
des objets ici et donc dernière chose il
y aura des effectifs de police
supplémentaires sur le carnaval cette
année nous aurons aussi nous des
médiateurs qui seront présents de
manière mobile pour aller sur tous les
points si nécessaire près de 150 000
personnes sont attendues sur les quatre
jours du carnaval entre ce dimanche et
le mercredi des Cendres le défi pour la
ville sera donc aussi culturel en
favorisant une cohabitation entre
tradition et modernité nos personnages
traditionnels seront valorisés dans
dans la société actuelle il faut faire
revivre ce témoignage là c'est mémoire
là et se dire un martiniquais c'est quoi
c'est qui et comment vous le gars
l'affirmer en tant que tel ça passe
aussi par le carnaval et ça passe
absolument par le carnaval autre
considération plus pratique si parking
périphériques soit 3000 places de
stationnement et des navettes de 13h30 à
20h ont été organisés pour permettre au
public d'accéder à la fête dans les rues
de Fort-de-France en toute sérénité
[Musique]